Chris asks what surprises or interest
you about brands with high brand equity
but don't have huge budget Chris this is
a great question I also love the
Instagram photo this whole Instagram
thing is gonna be awesome as a matter
fact you know what I almost didn't do
this episode so do Drock I know you're
disappointed with only two questions but
that's better than zero and you've heard
that before you like that like that's
the fun so um so that actually gives me
a second here to push the vaynernation
because I know we went out super late
the other night Instagram photos
Instagram questions let's link up how
you do that let's get on that for the
rest of the week chris is a great
question you know look this is why I
love social media I believe that social
media is the plumbing to word-of-mouth
in our society and I think there's a lot
of brands that don't spend marketing
that just win on having a great product
if you make a great product and you get
people to taste it physically and
literally meaning try your app you know
check out your store wear your hoodie or
actually try sauce and it's delicious
word of mouth will kick in I think the
world we live in now it actually speeds
that up because when somebody had that
sauce now they take a photo and put an
Instagram be like this is delicious
that's a lot better than 1997 we're like
I have this sauce and then like Stefan
and I are playing basketball like oh by
the way this sauce like what I did that
one's like it was impossible to amplify
the way we are now on an individual
person level so I actually think the era
of companies with very limited or zero
marketing budgets is here and I do think
social media is that foundation so what
interests me is that this is the
greatest time ever to not have a
marketing budget in a world as a
marketer because so much of it can be
organic and authentic it's hard you have
to be great and most of all your product
has to be sensational so I think the
brands that will break out the products
that will break out in the next half
decade with zero dollars are gonna be
anomalies but that's predicated on them
actually making a phenomenal product